let's start with a warm-up problem to
avoid getting any mental cramps as we
learn new things so this is a problem
that hopefully if you understood what we
did in the last video you can kind of
understand what we're about to do right
now and I'm going to escalate it even
more in the last video we finished with
a I think we finished with a four digit
number times a one digit number let's
let's let's up the stakes to a five
digit number so let's do 6400 let's do
sixty-four thousand three hundred and
twenty nine times now let me think of a
nice number times four times four I'm
going to show you right now that this is
we're going to do the exact same process
that we did in the last video we just
have to do it a little bit longer than
we did before so we just start off
saying okay what's four times nine four
times nine is equal to 36 right 18 times
2 we got 36 so we write the six down
here carry the 3 up there just put the
three up there then you got 4 times 2 4
times 2 4 times 2 and then you're going
to have to add the 3 so let me just
write that there plus 3 is equal to you
do the multiplication first so you can
even think of it as an order of
operations but you know you just should
know that you do the multiplication
first so it's 8 plus so 4 times 2 is 8
plus 3 is equal to 11 put the this one
down here and put the 1 10 and 11 up
there then you got 4 times 3/4 times 3/4
times 3 you got that one up there so you
have to add that plus 1 is equal to
that's going to equal 12 plus 1 is equal
to 13 so 13 then you have 4 times 4 4
times 4 you have this little one hanging
out here from the previous
multiplication so you have to add that
and that's equal to 16 plus 1 it's equal
to 17 take the 7 down here put the one
up there
we're almost done almost done
we have four times six four times six
plus one plus one what is that 4 times 6
is 24 plus 1 is 25 but the 5 down here
there's nowhere to put the - there's no
more multiplications to do so we just
put the 2 down there so 64 thousand
three hundred and twenty-nine times four
is two hundred and fifty-seven thousand
three hundred and sixteen and in case
you're wondering these commas don't mean
much they just help me read the number
so I put it after every three digits so
I know that for example that everything
after this these are in the thousand
thousand I've had another comma here
then I know this is millions so it just
helps me read the problem a bit so if
you got that you're now ready to
escalate to the to a slightly more
complicated situation although the first
way that we're going to do it it's
actually not going to look any more
complicated it's just going involve one
more step so everything we've done so
far are a bunch of digits times a one
digit number now let's do a bunch of
digits times a two digit number so let's
say we want to multiply let's say we
want to multiply 36 times instead of
putting a one digit number here I'm
gonna put a two digit number so times 23
aha
so you start off doing this problem
exactly the way you would have done it
if there was just a three down here you
can kind of ignore the two for a little
bit so three times six three times six
is equal to 18 so you put the eight here
put the 10 there or the one there
because it's 10 plus 8 3 times 3 is 9 3
times 3 is 9 plus 1 so 3 times 3 plus 1
is equal to this 9 plus 1 is equal to 10
so you put the 10 there there's nothing
left you put the 0 there there's nothing
left to put the ones you put the 10
there so you essentially have solved the
problem that 36 let me do this in
another color that 36 times 3 is equal
to 108 that's what we've solved so far
but we have this 20 sitting out here
all right we have this 20 we have to
figure out what 20 times 360 is or sorry
what 20 times 36 is so what you do to
multiply this is this 2 is really a 20
and to make it all work out like that
what we do is we throw a 0 down here we
throw a 0 right there and in a second
I'm going to explain why exactly we did
that so let's just do the same process
as we did before with the 3 now we do it
with the 2 but we start filling up here
and move to the left so 2 times 6 2
times 6 that's easy that's 12 so 2 times
6 is 12 we put the one up here and we
have to be very careful because we had
this one from our previous problem which
doesn't apply anymore so we could erase
it or you know that one we could get rid
of you have an eraser you get rid of it
or you can just keep tracking your head
that the one you're about to write is a
different one so what were we doing we
wrote 2 times 6 is 12 put the 2 here put
the one up here and I got rid of the
previous one because that will just mess
me up now I have 2 times 3 2 times 3 is
equal to 6 but then I have this plus 1
up here so I have to add plus 1 so I get
7 so that is equal to 7 2 times 3 plus 1
is equal to 7 so this 720 we just solved
that's literally let me write that down
what is that that is 36 times 20 36
times 20 is equal to 720 and hopefully
that should explain why we had to throw
this 0 here if we didn't throw that 0
here we would have just a 2 we would
just have a 72 here instead of a 720 and
72 is 36 times 2 but this isn't the 2
this is a 2 in the tens place this is a
20 so we have to multiply 36 times 20
and that's where we got 720 there so 36
times 23 let's write it this way let me
write it let me get some space up here
so we could write 30 well actually let
me just finish the problem then I'll
explain to you why it worked so now to
finish it up we just add
108 to 720 so 8 plus 0 is 8 0 plus 2 is
2 1 plus 7 is 8 so 36 times 23 is 828
now you're saying Sal why did that work
how why were we able to figure out
separately 36 times 3 is equal to 108
and then 36 times 20 is equal to 720 and
then add them up like that because we
could have rewritten the problem like
this we could have rewritten the problem
as 36 let me write the original problem
was this we could have rewritten this as
36 times 20 plus 3 and this and I don't
know if you've learned the distributive
property yet but this is just the
distributive property this is just the
same thing as 36 times 20 plus 36 times
3 if that confuses you then you don't
have to worry about it but if it doesn't
then then this is good it's actually
teaching you something 36 times 20 we
saw was 720 we learned that 36 times 3
was 108 and when you added them together
we got what 828 so what we got we got
828 and you could expand it even more
like we did in the previous video you
could write this out as 30 plus 6 times
20 plus 3 actually let me just do it
that way because I think that could help
you out a little bit if it confuses you
ignore it if it doesn't that's good so
we can do it 3 times 6 3 times 6 is 18
18 is just 10 plus 8 so it's 8 and we
put a 10 up here and ignore all this up
here 3 times 33 times 30 is 90 90 plus
10 is a hundred so 100 is 0 tens plus
100 I don't know if this confuses you or
not if it does ignore it if it doesn't
well you know I don't want to I don't
want to complicate the issue and now we
can multiply 20 we could ignore this
thing that we had before we're ready 20
times
is 120 so that's 20 plus 100 plus 100 so
I'll put that hundred up here 20 times
30 you might not notice 2 times 3 and
you have 2 zeroes there and I think I'm
maybe jumping the gun a little bit
assuming a little bit too much of what
you may or may not know but 20 times 30
is going to be 600 and you add another
100 there that's 700 and then you add
them all up you get 800 all right 100
plus 700 plus 20 plus 8 which is equal
to 828 my point here is to show you why
that system we did worked why we added a
0 here to begin with but if it confuses
you don't worry about that right now
learn how to do it and then maybe
re-watch this video let's just do a
bunch of more examples because I think
the examples are what really hopefully
explain the situation so let's do 77
let's do a fun one 77 times 77 7 times 7
is 49 put the one up here the one up
there
7 times 7 well that's 49 plus 4 is 53 53
there's nowhere to put the 5 so we put
it down here 7 times 7 is 49 plus 4 is
53 stick a 0 here now we're going to do
this 7 so let's take a 0 here 7 times
and we get let's get rid of this right
there because that'll just mess us up 7
times 7 is 49 stick a 9 there put a 4
there 7 times 7 is 49 plus 4 which is 53
53 so notice when we multiplied 7 times
77 we got 539 when we multiplied 7d
times 77 we got 5390 it makes sense they
just differ by a 0 by a factor of 10 and
now we can just add them up and what do
we get 9 plus 0 is 9 3 plus 9 is 12
carry the 1
1 plus 5 is 6 6 plus 3 is
nine nine and then we have this five so
it's five thousand nine hundred and
twenty nine